thank you thanks for having me here i am
originally from Texas over to UT so I
didn't think that the first time I would
be in front of a classroom would be
outside of my home state but it's great
to be here raise your hand if you've
heard of Britain CO or no of Britain co
before her if this ok awesome good
before this is before you even did that
intro I'm going to have a pretty candid
discussion with you guys today I'm going
to tell you about kind of my path to
becoming an entrepreneur the hard times
the happy time it's been four years now
as of Monday that I've started Britain
co I did it all by myself in the very
beginning literally alone in my
apartment in San Francisco and now we
have a team of over 80 people have
raised over 30 million in funding so
I'll tell you all about that I'm also
going to talk a lot about creativity and
why I think it's important not just for
us as human beings but for society at
large and how it ties into the maker
movement which is something I'm very
passionate about as well but before we
get started I wanted to paint the
mission of Britain co especially for
those of you who might not have known
about Britain co before today and this
started as an experiment that we did and
I had the hypothesis when I was starting
this company that adults and especially
adult women don't think they are very
creative I am my girlfriend's all the
time and even myself occasionally would
just save literally things like I wish I
were creative I wish I were an artist um
and I kept asking like why why would you
say that when you were three four or
five years old I'm sure that if people
put blocks or Legos or Plato or crayons
in front of you you went to town and you
just doughnut when T 5 year olds and so
I got a group of the five year olds and
put them into a room and asked them to
do a lot of creative things and then I
got the 25 ish year olds and put them
into a room I asked them to do the same
thing I we caught it all on video and
here's what happened I'm
to take one this is a really fun one
okay I want you to pick any of those
capes that you like and I want you to
think about and become a character and I
want you to act out that character okay
ready set go hi Elizabeth ready to go
play she want to jump rope now we use
our modulation a lot okay you can paint
whatever you want i painted me and my
dog playing um it's almost morning kind
and those are little pieces of gay and
that's the grass that's the dirt and
under it is just all color
um
if that just a bunch of slashes and dots
I'm not an artist I love painting I
consider going to art school when I was
a lot younger my life took a different
path and I rarely paint my former dream
job as a kid I loved drawing and I loved
doodling and animation what would you do
in your life to be more creative just
make time for it you know I have a busy
life and oftentimes that's something
that can fall by the wayside how did it
feel just some general to be creative
today it was very hard
now we go play some more loud cookie
now it's done and I will put it back on
this table to cool off and then we dance
some more that was awesome it was really
really fun did anything scary you were
oh not at all it was awesome it was the
best day of my life mm-hmm so that went
the way I thought it would thank God
because we invested a lot into making
that video but that fundamentally is our
mission at Burton co and and I saw the
same pattern in my own life this was me
as a little girl was a Girl Scout I
loved making things loved creating
things and took art classes as a kid
this is my third grade masterpiece was
constantly doodling and drawing into my
early teenage years and then I got a
cell phone and I became obsessed with
technology and I started taking computer
science classes and I really just cared
about getting straight to Silicon Valley
I actually graduated college at UT early
almost two years early and came straight
out here all through college I was
interning with Silicon Valley companies
I ended up taking a job at apple I was
working in itunes this was itunes pre
anything but music and so that was a
really fun job i was going to concerts a
lot i was meeting with record labels a
lot starting to learn a little bit more
about the entertainment industry and
then i went to google for about four
years i started on the search team i'm
sorry i start on the maps team and then
moved to search products worked for
Marissa Meyer who's now become a great
mentor of mine I was working in product
management and product marketing and
ultimately they asked me if I would go
over to the YouTube division and head up
a new product we were going to be
launching called google TV Google TV ham
was a android based platform that really
brought everything you love about the
internet and Internet video to your
television and it was my job not only to
launch this product I was given
literally tens of em
ends of dollars as a 24 year old to go
do that but I also had to convince
content networks cable operators all
kinds of content providers to digitize
their content and put it on the Internet
this is back in like 2009 and back then
that was such a foreign topic for them
they you know I would meet with people
like a DC and the New York Times and CNN
and they'd ask like what Google just
wants to take over the world like you
just want our content Laurie we're not
going to do this like we need to know
how to digitize our content and where no
one's ever going to watch internet video
they're only going to watch television
and I was just kind of like shocked
because I was like are you joking like
that's all people want to watch if
especially we can turn on your TV in
your living room and have the option to
watch a New York Times video or an ABC
family like movie marathon like who
cares it's videos video so what I saw
when I was doing that was that these
traditional media companies were pretty
behind in their thinking and even if
they were forward thinking about
digitizing their content there were
large businesses that were moving very
slowly what they did have however was a
lot of eyeballs you know these people
actually wouldn't even want to talk to
Google sometimes because they didn't
care they already had mass distribution
and they did have a lot of advertising
dollars as well and most of them cared
mostly about the brands of their shows
and their characters and their cast
members and what I thought about what I
was doing even working and YouTube it
was the same thing it was people
connecting with people in Silicon Valley
that's a foreign concept because you
build an app and just try to make it
viral and you don't really think about
the brand or really connecting with a
community of people behind the screen
but in the media world that's all anyone
cares about its having that emotional
experience and creating really high
quality content anyways fast forward I
left Google when I was 25 because I felt
like after having a few years under my
belt at Apple and Google and I would
ready to try something new and to take a
risk and to start a company of my own
and I knew I wanted to do it in the tech
space that was where I was based I had a
lot of connections at that point and
being 25 there's not a lot to lose I was
not yet married I had made enough money
and app on Google to save up a little
bit of money to get started and I didn't
have to worry about you know funding a
family or kids or so forth so but first
it took a few months off I decided I
needed to just like chill out a little
bit I'd worked really hard I you know
graduated college early my friends but I
was crazy for doing that and I what I
miss the most was actually doing things
with my hands it had been years since I
had actually made stuff and just so
happened the same month I left Google
this place called tech shop opened in
San Francisco who knows what tech shop
is not that many people so it's
basically like a gym for making things
you pay about ninety-nine bucks a month
and you can come in anytime and use all
of these really cool machines ranging
from 3d printers and laser cutters to
digital sewing machines and screen
printers and vinyl cutters and you
really just get to go to town I had such
a fun time at techshop I ended up being
there literally every day and I have no
idea how to use these machines when I
started but after understanding that
really what I was doing was creating
designs and photoshop or illustrator
pressing a button and exporting it onto
a laser cutter or 3d printer to create a
physical product my mind was blown and I
just wanted to do it over and over again
everyone around me at TechShop were
mostly men they were kind of working in
silos it didn't feel communal yet at the
same time that same year pinterest had
lunch and on pinterest it was all
millennial women and DIY was the top
category all they wanted to penn were
things about crafts and cooking recipes
and all kinds of things to make and I
was seemed kind of crazy to me because
while i was at techshop but i was doing
all this stuff my girlfriends would come
up to me like I told you before and say
like oh you're so creative i wish i were
creative like you and i was like
I know how to do this stuff a few months
ago it really wasn't that hard I just
like learned it there were like online
galleries and resources these machines
actually did the making and like I
didn't really do it and meanwhile they
were penny and all the things they
wanted to make so it seemed like there
is this Delta and this gap between them
aspiring to be creative but not actually
knowing how to be creative so brené
Brown says this I'm not very creative
doesn't work there's no such thing as
creative people non-creative people
they're only people who use their
creativity and those who don't and I
fully agree with this statement and that
again is the point of my business and
that's when the light bulb did go off
and I was like is this the business like
how could I make this a business clearly
I'm really passionate about it and I
could see myself doing this for a long
time it matters in the world it's a
problem I see I so I started looking at
the industry and I of course I thought
of Martha Stewart it was like she was
the leader of creativity for like my mom
and my mom's mom but you know she's um
it doesn't really resonate with today's
consumer like the stuff Mart they would
make would be like beautiful cakes and
table settings that might take you the
whole day but it would be really amazing
and your friends would be so jealous and
it felt really aspirational but not
really relatable today's society has
maybe 30 minutes has never done it
before like it's totally freaked out
about doing it in the first place so
what are like the hacks to get them
there faster I also thought about the
you know retail world of crafting and
arts and crafts Michaels is the leader
of that space they do five billion
dollars revenue a year followed closely
by joannes and hobby lobby who each do
multi billions dollars of revenue as
well the whole craft industry at large
in the US alone is a 34 billion dollar
industry which has not been disrupted in
a very long time then I started of
course going to data so i looked up
terms on google search trends how to had
been growing over the years 3d printing
of course was a new technology that was
starting to grow as a search term and
the maker movement which i found the
most interesting was a turn that denim
exist before about two thousand seven or
two thousand eight so the maker movement
is about this new cultural shift and how
people especially young people want to
be making and creating and how these new
types of machines and Internet resources
are helping them do that so why is all
this happening now why are the young
people really interested in this I have
some hypotheses I think a lot of it is
cultural so we're seeing each other do
it a lot we you know we're scenes trends
of artisanal we're back lashing it
against packaged food brands and we
don't want to buy frozen dinners anymore
like I know my parents bought me in the
80s and early 90s and we want to shop
small and support our local communities
we also have a research report that says
I could actually buy the right resources
I could make products that are better
than the ones i buy in stores and this
is from about 20 to 50 year olds
consumers who said that i also just
think like we're tired of screen
sometimes sometimes we want to
disconnect and we haven't been able to
do that this is the first generation
that's really grown up without being
forced to take home economics Sarah shop
class he's had two working parents while
they were growing up as children and
really just never learned to do this
stuff before finally it's just our human
nature look back at our ancestors they
literally had to create to survive they
had to build things they had to cook for
themselves it was a part of society now
of course we can outsource all these
things that we want to we can post mates
our dinner over if we want to we can
have people do all the building and
making for us but inside we are
literally made to be creators so I
decided to do this as a business I
really didn't know exactly how I was
going to do it but I knew I had to just
start and I I went back to my google
roots especially for the google TV roots
I thought if I'm going to attract a
large audience I don't want to have to
pay for that audience so I'm going to
create a lot of a really amazing content
that's going to get them to come to the
site then I can mark it whatever it is I
end up wanting to market to them for
free and hopefully I can actually teach
them some things as well so I literally
did this all on my own
I spent a few months just making content
I was the photographer the editor the
writer the CEO the accountant everything
I did have a outsource design agency i
think i paid five thousand dollars to
make our like kind of now looks get a
website and I did all my press alone
actually scored in LA Times article on
the day of launch which was like huge in
my opinion I tried to pretend like I was
a 10-person company when I was a
one-person company um and I just kept
deciding to like keep going it was
really hard at first um I actually said
this in the launch blog post I wrote
which is creating things businesses
products software and crafts my life's
destiny it's my true passion and I
couldn't be more excited about putting
my knowledge and skills to use to help
others live a more creative and
efficient life at home it's nice to look
back at that actually found that on
Monday which was our four year
anniversary like I told you and to see
that your mission hasn't really changed
in four years is something a lot of
startups can't say so I feel proud
though that Lee's bad still intact um
hiring team is the next step so again I
was bootstrapping this for the first few
months my first two hires were that guy
he was our first engineer his name's
Paul and has been the girl in the back
behind him what that was a cooking
off-site for our team was our first kind
of writer content creator creative
director kind of all rolled up in one
the other girl was a freelancer who
helped create content as well and the
goal at first was to just couldn't
continue to create a lot of content but
to build these ancillary apps that we
would use to create utilities in
people's lives and we were starting with
all the life stages we want to do a
wedding and home and baby and pets and
create ways that people could be
creative through software and that's
what our team ended up looking like
after the first year we've had about
nine people and we ended up actually
raising over a million dollars as our
seed round about six months in we raised
from mostly silicon valley investors a
lot of big names as well as some angels
as well and that round
booze really again to launch our first
app and to create the content around it
that would help drive people to that up
um just to touch on this you know being
a woman this is a question I get asked
about in Silicon Valley quite a bit
especially every reporter asked me about
it all the time um and my response is
this I think it actually can set you
apart clearly there are a lot of men in
the students I'm sorry but if you are a
woman you're thinking about starting in
business I have had the opportunity to
not only create a business for women
mostly by women we have about three
quarters of our staff are women but it's
a women by the most things they're the
biggest consumers on the internet they
consume the most content as well there
hopefully going to be President one day
and they it's a great way to set
yourself apart from what everyone else
especially in Silicon Valley is doing
they're far too few women and I think
those who actually are starting as
entrepreneurs really can't stand out um
so the first year these are some images
and that's us taking out the trash in
the office like it was a scrappy year
and again we had about nine people by
the end of the year this is in 2012 and
we would also do photo shoots that were
really i'm going to use the word again
get out like we would go up to the roof
and pretend like we're in some like
fancy and city or something and it
actually ended up looking nice like that
was in the SF Chronicle on the far left
at the far right but it wasn't that
glamorous behind the scenes we didn't
have a professional photographer like we
were really faking it till we were
making it and so kind of like in summary
again over a million raised 19 members
we did actually have a small pivot so a
few months and like I told you we were
creating these acts and thinking about
this whole strategy as content marketing
for the apps the content itself was like
becoming really popular and so we sort
of paused halfway through the year and
decided let's actually just focus all of
our effort on growing this company as a
media business instead of an app
business and see what happens we
actually started testing commerce as
well so DIY and creativity are kind
the essence of what we do we decided to
create DIY kits as a subscription
business kind of a birch box for DIY so
every month people would get a different
project with all the supplies and
components they need to put it together
in a kit and we right off the bat have
hundreds of subscribers so it was going
pretty well started going on television
um I put my name in the company
primarily because I wanted people to
understand that I was authentic as a
person behind this brand but I cared
about it that I was the target consumer
and could relate to our our demographic
that we were reaching but I call it
Britain and co and the co stands for
community and I wanted everyone else to
feel like they were part of that
community as well so our community today
consists not only of all of our users
but of designers makers artists all
kinds of creative people who we
highlight around the site and i'll talk
more about that later anyways it did
help me though secure different types of
press opportunities because there was a
face to this brand so the today show
called up midway through the first year
to ask me to come on and it was crazy to
think that my childhood dream of going
on today show could come true and and it
happened and I was so nervous about it
and then they kept asking me back so
that was a big highlight of the first
year I think overall though the first
year of a start-up is just ups and downs
um every single day I'm a very numbers
driven person I would constantly be
tracking our analytics and if it was a
bad day I literally like wouldn't talk
to anyone the rest of the day didn't
want to go out to dinner at night I
think I would just go home and sulk it
was an amazing day I would have dreams
about like selling my company and
thinking like everything was going to be
amazing so it was just like this all the
time and of course we were scrappy like
I remember fond memories are like
ordering the toilet paper I'm thinking
like why didn't we have an office
manager yet like why am I the CEO doing
all this and that's just how it has to
be in that first year um so my learnings
data data data we use that data to
understand that our content business was
by far and away growing faster
than the app business and decided to
really focus our efforts there and that
leads the second point of keep your
mission don't be afraid if your
execution tactics need to change and if
you think you should fire someone it's
already too late I had to make my first
fire that first year we had an engineer
literally he brought in a six-pack one
day to work and just kept drinking and
weird i was like what it's happening it
was a really amazing engineer but had a
really terrible attitude and in Silicon
Valley amazing engineers are there are
many of them but it's really hard when
you're small startups to attract them so
it was a really hard thing for me to
have to let that person go but it was
right for the company and be a waffle
there's this book called women are
spaghetti and men or waffles and which
is basically about how our emotions
interact with each other so women like
have a guess the point of this from the
author's perspective the women have all
these emotions and they're loosely
framed and men just compartmentalize
things and can easily move from one
thing to the next and I learned in that
first year that you really have to
control your emotions and you have to be
able to fire someone one minute and step
into a an interview with The New York
Times the next minute and be extremely
positive and happy about everything
going on in your life um and that's just
the way that business works the second
year we were starting to outgrow our
space we literally had conference rooms
and bathroom and again to the scrappy
theme and we did double in size though
so and we raised a Series A so we raised
over six million dollars continuing to
secure a really great press about twenty
team members we ended up killing
subscriptions the business I was talking
to you about not because it wasn't
working but because our customers really
wanted to customize all of their
products and so in their projects so
they wanted to make jewelry instead of
home decor they wanted a baking project
and operationally it was just not
possible so we decided to sort of put a
can on it until we rethought commerce
and what that meant for us instead we up
leveled our content we
finally hired a professional
photographer we hired more editors we
hired a sales team so we could actually
start making money we launched a new
york office we launched remake which
Tina actually was was able to sneak out
this year this is our third year doing
it the first year remake is a conference
in a festival and the conference is
focused on all of the biggest
influencers and the maker movement
ranging from neuro scientists to artists
to musicians and the festival is a place
for the general public to come and
actually just get their hands dirty
learning how to make stuff and shopping
from makers and artisans and so that was
a really big deal for us we did secure
major partnership deals I became a
spokesperson for companies like Target
and even velcro and we were beginning to
really get into the press cycle more and
more considering to do television and
things like that as well so this is
really a good growth year for us um
biggest learnings hire a sales team as
soon as possible I was probably about a
year too late on this and learning that
I could do a million dollars in revenue
and a year was shocking to me and it was
really just took a small team of sales
people to go make that happen shake them
haters off so especially when you are
the face in the name of a brand you're
gonna get haters you're going to get
people critiquing you all the time that
was probably one of the hardest lessons
I had to learn in 2013 the second year
um it's it's difficult I celebrities
talk about this all the time I guess but
it's like everyone has an opinion about
you and the work you're doing and why
you're doing it and what your motives
are um now my response to this is that
if you believe you are truly a good
person it was really kind to people and
you have a good mission you just want to
help people do more of like what they
want to be doing I don't know if anyone
can actually bring you down so that's
been my response to all the haters and
then content quality is king so as soon
as we level we up leveled our content I
mean traffic just exploded we had
amazing photography amazing journalism
and writing
and we really saw a bat payback for us
the third year and our team we didn't
actually have to fundraise which was a
big deal if you don't have to fundraise
you shouldn't we doubled again to about
40 people this is last year 2014 um and
I would say this is the year we really
truly found product market fit we were
tripling if not quadrupling and growth
year-over-year both from a revenue
perspective and a user perspective um we
did reenter commerce again and we
started by really testing we did two
weeks friends um which you know we would
put a new product out there meaning a
software product and a different
variation of Commerce and in two weeks
or maybe a month max we would understand
if it was successful so we had
parameters set up to understand engage
what do people want to buy from us um
what what do they not want to buy from
us and let's do more of that and less of
the things that they don't want to do we
ended up finding that people really
wanted to come to us to learn they
wanted to take classes about how to do
this stuff because we didn't know how so
we started launching classes ranging
from calligraphy to coding to cake
decorating to digital photography
started giving them the kits of all the
supplies they needed to take those
classes so if you want to take
calligraphy you can get the inks and the
pens and the papers and everything you
need and we found that they also wanted
to support artists sins and makers but
they sort of felt like going to a place
like Etsy was a little overwhelming
there was so much supply of product that
no one was really true eating it down
but we were really great at especially
being a media company was duration and
editorializing things and products so we
launched a marketplace um a curated
marketplace of different types of makers
and their products I was pregnant last
year that's me on stage at remake again
last year literally 37 weeks pregnant
and that was really crazy I literally
could have been in labor if I
I hopefully I didn't I was actually a
week late to another story but um it was
it was his nuts like I had a lot of
women entrepreneurs that I knew but not
many that had been kind of in the thick
of their growing their business while
they're having their first child and um
you know it's hard you you think like
what are my employees going to think
what are my investors going to think we
do have to raise another round of
financing soon like what do we do about
that can I walk into a new venture
capitalists office like 37 weeks
pregnant and go raise money and and so
it was difficult and made it through but
decided to fund raise in january instead
of in q4 of last year which which meant
that i basically had a month or two
after having a baby so like pull myself
together and go pitch investors um
meanwhile i was writing a book our first
book i was hiring our first adults so
people over 40 is when i qualify as
adult and which it which like really can
shake up the culture of a start-up when
you're like all people in their 20s and
early 30s um we also were testing retail
businesses so we launched a pop-up store
in San Francisco which was all based on
experiential retail so people could come
in they could take classes they can like
sit down and do free projects they could
also buy goods from our makers so it was
a combination of traditional retail an
experiential retail and we also tested
wholesale sweary we are making all these
kits and products and we wanted to test
if they would sell in other stores and
so we put them into different types of
retail stores all around the country
this was a big year learnings from that
year product market fit is crucial um
this is something that you should if
you're an entrepreneur strive to get you
as soon as possible it's what your
investors will continue to invest money
in and if you aren't there they will not
company cultural changes should be
expected as you scale we had a lot of
pushback from you know our 25-year old
engineers who are like what are we
hiring an adult the suit like and if we
had 200
explain like why it would be good for
the business and why the culture like
wouldn't get super process heavy and
pregnancy bias is a real thing like I
did have to rethink our fundraising
schedule because our board didn't want
me walking into a venture capitalist
office like eight months pregnant and
it's conquerable we got through it but
it's not the greatest thing and it does
detract from with your female
entrepreneur who's young and wants to
have a family the fourth year we
continue to grow so this is this year
I'm get to catch you up we raised 20
million dollars so after going through
that labor and delivery process I went
right out into the streets and started
pitching and got a lot of really great
interest brought in some amazing
investors raised 20 million dollars
which has now enabled us to hire 80
people and the book launched a couple
months later and made the bestseller
list that was a big highlight of this
year to a tree make this year we had
over 10,000 attendees come out which was
huge so we've been doubling attendance
at that event every year we now have
tens of millions of people every month
coming to our sites and are different
all of our different platforms that were
on and we have made a deeper investment
in commerce and online education we now
have posted 50 classes online we have
thousands of products in our marketplace
continued TV and major press got invited
to the White House to interview our CTO
Megan Smith and the White House has also
invested in a department of making them
which is a new initiative to get more
people into making and they truly
believe in the maker movement and what
it can do for STEM education in America
we actually just a couple weeks ago put
our first real product into all target
stores which is actually a coloring book
for adults and I'll get to that in a
second and we launched a foundation
which first startup and it's you know
third or fourth year is kind of unheard
of but it's called the I am creative
foundation and even though we aren't
we're getting grin
up to fifteen thousand dollars to women
and girls for their big creative
pursuits of course that's not millions
of dollars but it is something and it's
pretty meaningful and we've been able to
now fund five different women 1 13 year
old as part of that to go out and open
photo studios to teach after-school
programs to girls and teach them how to
create fashion tech hardware and then go
sell that at different Maker Faires
around the country we've been able to
make differences in people's lives which
is the startup is really meaningful and
then we launched a video so we'll up
till now we've been doing a lot of
editorial content a lot of written
content and we really wanted to focus on
video kind of going back to my google TV
roots again i'm going to show you just a
couple of quick videos that we have so
you can understanding what that means
so this first one is really just basic
at the how to series that we created
I
you
Oh
so again just kind of trying to bring to
life some of these projects and ideas
and teaching people that they they're
pretty easy and you can learn all of
that in under 60 seconds in a video
we've also done more documentary style
videos and really starting to think
about you know back to the google TV
days how do we start creating digital
video content that can maybe one day you
go to television instead of vice versa
creating television content that become
digital I'll just play like a few
seconds of this next video so you see
you see the dramatic difference of the
type of video quality that we're
producing
there's no real recipe of how I I work
my opinions and outrage slowly grow in
me based on my everyday experience and
things that I see the way the media
portrays women and sexuality that
bothers me a lot the importance of how
you look a certain way of being feminine
that is something that goes very deep in
your self-esteem I think that has been
the tool to keep us down so it goes on
for a few minutes but the point is that
we're doing a variety of different types
of creative directions with video by the
way that woman she was working at a at
age enci hated all the way that the
media was stereotyping women in
advertising and started decided to start
vandalizing their content and putting up
pictures on top of it it's a different
story about creativity and about art
that we really wanted to tell it's a
little deeper and a little bit darker
anyways our brand is expanding though to
think about all the different ways we
can tell stories about art and
creativity that aren't just practical
how-to projects we really are trying to
be really mass and understanding the
world of creativity so my last year what
have I learned moms are superheroes it's
true I feel like a real superhero
there's literally a point in my day when
I was like out there pitching doing
press interviews for the book launch I
was breast pumping in the back of a car
like an uber and the guy was like what's
happening in the back seat and it was
totally nuts so I've had to completely
change my life in my schedule and
randomly like this has been our best and
most successful year yet so I don't know
maybe there's an alignment there and
don't be afraid to hire expensive people
they do the job of two or more people so
this is the first year I really like
up leveled our executive team I hired a
CFO which I like wish I would have hired
three years ago because I hate
everything related to the CFO job
function like I just hate spreadsheets
and having her here has given me so much
more free time to go and do the things I
love to do and to focus my time on
building the vision of the business the
product and engineering organization the
content organization the video
organization and so anyways that's the
second one and the last is two most
important come eat rates have been
communication and focus so there's a
period when you're under growth between
50 150 employees this is a pattern that
happens to all startups where you go
from this team that everyone knows each
other and everyone kind of hangs out
together to there being clicks that form
to hiring your first real HR person your
first lawyer there's more processes and
everyone starts getting upset and clicky
and like passive aggressive the thing
that you have to do the most is over
communicate why you're doing the things
you're doing why you're making the
changes you're making that you know
reinforced how important everyone is on
your team and reinforce the focus of the
business you can't be doing a million
things you have to really focus on the
things that are working and do more of
those so what's next well for Britain Co
we're going to continue to really scale
as you know media business we're going
to keep doing more video more editorial
the media has like really beautifully
aligned into this online education
platform which is another version an
adaptation of video in my opinion and
then continuing to create products and
to help other makers sell their products
and that's kind of what we're up to but
more importantly I'm interested in
what's happening in mass culture and
there are two trends that I'm really
seeing the first is mainstream
creativity literally as I was driving
down here today and New York Times
reporter called me wanting to interview
me because she's under the pretense that
creativity is the next meditation and
that's exactly what I've been starting
to think about this year we've had
that's like under the pre same for
instance and why we met I'm fascinated
with the neuroscience behind
creativity and how it really can impact
your brain this is me at Burning Man
this year's the first time I ever went
it was a crazy experience and I was
there for two days and I thought it was
like this crazy rave in the desert but
what I found was that it was this
beautiful place where people were making
art and and not they weren't afraid to
express themselves there this woman is
dressed up all in tutus like literally
that's all she's wearing and she's
really crazy celebrities even are
starting to go to this festival and
they're experimenting with their own
creativity in the way that they dress
and the way they act I look at my son
who's now one his name is Ansel and he
wants nothing more than just to do
creative stuff all day long and again
like I keep coming back to this like why
is this good for humans adults and kids
alike we tend to find that there's a lot
of data about how creativity can be good
for your well-being and so can reduce
cognitive impairment as you're aging and
we also find that anxiety disorders
which are the most common mental illness
in the u.s. is the most common is help
is helped by creativity um coloring
books and back to kind of my point there
are one of the things that are helping
people with anxiety and depression relax
and destress four of the top ten amazon
products from this year our adult
coloring books all of amazon products
for the top 10 um 30 million globally
are affected sorry 350 million are
affected by depression so imagine the
impact that we can make if more people
are participating and creative projects
that can help them release stress
anxiety and tension and more about the
brain we're really working to understand
what's happening with the brain there
are actually people here at Stanford who
we're working with here completing
research studies that have lasted for
five years and our understanding how the
brain is impacted by creativity and if
it's a muscle that can actually be
trained similar to muscles in your body
and how they're trained when you're
exercising sneak peek yes it does get
stronger as you practice some more
and this was an example of the coloring
book we launched just to start proving
this stuff to the mainstream culture we
did it in partnership with crayola and
we're continuing to scale our online
classes like I said I really think part
of the reason what people aren't
participating in creative projects is
because they don't know how to start
they literally don't have the skills
that they needed that other past
generations had the maker movement
though is what's more exciting to me and
this is something that will continue to
get bigger and bigger every year like
you saw in that google search graph it's
about everything from kind of the analog
world of making it in creativity
traditional arts like letterpress which
are coming back but also all the
benefits that technology is bringing to
how we're making and creating we're able
to open source our designs so that
others can freely download them and
access them there are online learning
platforms not just from Britain Co but
from others as well where people are
able to get educated if they don't live
near a college university or any type of
work shop that offers classes umm 3d
rendering is so cool right now this is a
new startup called mod Z that launched
you can literally take a picture of any
room in your house and they'll 3d render
it and show you what real furniture
looks like in that room they're
importing products from like West Elm in
crate and barrel and letting you swap
things in and out so from interior
designers perspective like this is a new
way to think about creativity um smart
devices of course and machines that are
helping us learn things faster this is a
favorite example of mine is called the
gee-tar it's an iphone connected guitar
it literally shows you the chords from
an app on your phone that you should be
playing so it teaches you how to play
the guitar just from looking at your
phone um crowdfunding of course is
what's enabling all of these small
entrepreneurs and startups to actually
get started we've seen some amazing new
products launched because of Kickstarter
and IndieGoGo there's only more of that
to come 3d printers which has not yet
gone mainstream for sure they're still
very expensive quality isn't there
yet but they are getting way better
people are using them to create human
tissue and bone to create all kinds of
food I'm an advisor for a company that's
actually using 3d printers to create
real clothing and textiles through
process club electronic spinning and and
in the future imagine going into your
closet downloading a blouse design from
j.crew pressing prints and having it
export for you in a glass machine like
this is a real future that's literally
years in front of us so what does this
mean this is all just a few years out
like we're in this moment before you
know when jet printers were only able to
be found at Kinkos and we're in that
moment with 3d printers right now and a
lot of the maker movement but soon we're
all going to have access to these
devices they're going to be just a
couple hundred bucks we're going to have
them on our desktops in our kitchens
they're going to be the way that we
produce and manufacture on our own and
so what implications could that have
something I'm thinking a lot about maker
spaces right now are the fedex and
kinkos of the world it's where people
are going to use these machines and
devices i think these will continue to
be popular for the next two years until
we see those price points fall the cost
of prototyping because of these maker
spaces has gone down significantly used
to have to prototype things in china for
like tens of thousands of dollars this
is the dodocase an ipad case you guys
might have seen it before literally it
was made in just a couple weeks for
about a thousand dollars Apple saw it
decided to pick it up in their online
store so like a million dollars a
product within its first month so all
for just a thousand bucks and a guy who
is tinkering with a laser cutter I'm
really excited about customization think
about the idea that if we have this long
tail manufacturing or you're able to
make stuff on your own you can add your
name to things you can add colors that
you like you can scan your body and make
things perfectly fit you the way you
want it to customization is going to be
a really big option for us in the future
but it does open us up to copyright
issues think of this a lot like the
music industry for all able to download
open source files what does that mean
does the designer who made the j.crew
blouse get credit when you do when you
download it does he get paid can I
illegally send that file to someone else
it's going to get really interesting
with the way that digital files are
transferred for product designs um the
whole nation like I mentioned the White
House is behind us is incredibly excited
about steam science technology
engineering art and math and I say steam
because art is included in that and the
White House is starting to use that term
as well but we're seeing kids especially
those and their early preteen years
really embrace this I'm meeting I mentor
a group of 12 year olds who actually
know more about CAD design than me and
it kind of freaks me out may also speak
Mandarin and so the future generations
are definitely on this but of course it
all comes back to play regardless of how
this affects our economy or different
industries I hope that people will also
just take time to participate in
creativity in their daily life one
exciting note to end on is that with all
of these changes the maker movement
people are predicting that the self
manufacturing in homes pit equate to a
55 billion dollar industry by the year
twenty twenty that's just five years
away this is on top of kind of the arts
and crafts industry that already exists
so this industry is only getting bigger
it's getting bigger very quickly to pay
attention that's the end of my talk I
have a few minutes for questions but I
hope everyone in here will also just
take away not only my story and what I
think is exciting about the future but
the fact that all of you I don't care
how old you are we're that kid one time
and played with Legos box paint hold
stories and you're still a person today
thank you
from eight minutes if anyone has a
question yep oh right yeah what would
you change like in your heightened
process you know how you said like I
wish I had some people earlier you know
like how you know would you change
anything about forget your heart she
asked but what would we change about the
way we hired in the order that we hired
I think coming out of the tech industry
I was very serious about hiring
engineers at first which is always a
good thing to do you know every company
today is a technology company and needs
engineers but I think a sales person
from the start would have been a really
smart higher the sooner you can start
creating and generating revenue and your
company the more freedom and autonomy
you have about whether or not you want
to raise more money whether you have to
and how how investors are valuing your
company and on that note if you're going
to be generating revenue hiring a CFO
who can really manage those budgets and
maximize kind of your profits and losses
is a really great thing to hire early on
as well yep in the back well as some
people say you know with great students
a cons more responsibilities to more
people I'm wondering how you balance all
this stuff you know the needs of the
venture falcomon needs of the people in
your company the philanthropy and of
course stuff that's healthy for yourself
questioning us how do i balance
everything so investors I have it we
have a foundation I have a real-life
sort of the question is the answer is
that it's it's an ongoing challenge I am
especially now that I have a family I'm
constantly torn between you know whether
to hang out with friends or to go home
and spend time with my son or to go to
an important business center that may or
may not lead to a major partnership or a
future round of financing and I have to
make these trade-offs all the time and
it sucks because you think about like in
five years my company completely crashes
and dies am I just wasting my way
my time by not spending it with my kids
or my friends and going to that business
center um but it puts the pressure on
you to make sure it's going to work and
for me this isn't you know a company
that I started just to try to make a lot
of money it's a company I started
because I'm genuinely passionate about
it and i genuinely believe there's a
problem in the world and a big
opportunity coming as a way to fix it
and I wanted to be part of that so um
I'm just excited because my life and my
work are almost one in the same and that
makes it easier to create that balance
yep right here can you tell me more
about how did you find problematic be
sure he wants to know how we found
product market fit serta goes back to
data and for us you know primarily being
a media company at the start we were
creating tons of different types of
content and I wasn't even sure what type
of user would want to ingest that
constant I had a hunch it would be women
similar in age to me in their 20s and
30s but the you know I didn't know if
they wanted beauty content or um
knitting or cooking or technology
content and so as we created more and
more of it we every day we're looking at
the numbers and understanding what to do
more on what to do less of and it's
become a really iterative process these
days to is a media company you're
putting your content on all these social
platforms and every social platform
responds differently so that's been a
big kind of awakening over the last year
we have we have over 40 million users a
month on pinterest alone and that
audience loves cooking crafting kind of
beauty content we do a ton of that type
of content just for that audience the
facebook audience we have over 20
million monthly users on the face our
facebook channel they love like trendy
pop culture of content how to get you
know someone's purple hair that they did
like Nicki Minaj decided her purple like
how did yours like that too so so it's a
little bit more celebrity infused a
little bit more pop culture and we've
learned through understanding analytics
of all these platforms including our own
how to
graham content for different channels
and different audiences I think it's
really interesting watching blake
lively's river friends that had just
such a short longevity um and I think
that there's a big trend in capitalizing
a pod with DIY and movement and so I'm
just wondering like what really do you
think distinguishes Britain Coast
success in comparison to other startups
like preserve that had failed in this
space sure um so yeah Blake Lively
launched the site it was a kind of an
artisanal marketplace sort of similar to
part of our commerce business her price
points were really high and it's that's
the best trade-off with this this
industry is that people that are making
things by hand they're spending
literally a month making an intricate
embroidered leather bag like they're
going to charge a thousand dollars for
that bag because they need to generate
revenue for them to live yet most
consumers that live in the fast fashion
world want to only pay 50 or 100 bucks
for that bag so it's hard because I
think their price points were a little
bit higher and also again like I think
it comes back to how do you get that
audience to engage with you on a daily
basis for us instead of having to pay to
acquire them through Google Adwords or
social channels we create content we
keep them coming back and give them
fresh new things to look at and
regardless of whether they're buying
something hopefully they're learning
something or they're inspired to want to
do something so i don't i don't know
that a commerce business in this space
that's selling high priced products is
always going to win it's just a hard
market with high price points so
different consumer yep so you talked
about how your first year that you
learned how to be a waffle end to a
compartment pop the car home Hartman
Eliza hawaiians your feelings yet um
other women on Channel right yep so as
you're growing and your your fourth year
is that becoming harder or easier so she
asked okay I'm a walk I was a waffle I
learned that my first year is it
becoming harder easier definitely easier
um I've gotten I think even better at it
my husband calls me a rock I'm just hard
to break it's you know anything can
happen to me good or bad and I just try
to stay solid and level
about it because I know in startup world
everything's temporary you raise it 20
million dollar round of financing and
everyone's giving you high fives and
press are writing about you all the time
and in the back of your mind as an
entrepreneur thinking like will we raise
again like is this going to let you know
like everything you're thinking about
the end of the world yet you just
secured runway for like two years so um
your thoughts are always going to go
back and forth and you just have to find
that middle ground I've gotten a lot
better just through experience in
practice yeah no one I co company have
you played in globalized yeah I should
have did you notice the hands and I went
at West next slide where Matt so we are
definitely thinking about that probably
i'm preparing for it in 2016 and
actually starting to globalize in 2017
the maker industry is happening
worldwide the maker movement the DIY
kind of culture it's not just in the
u.s. so we're really excited to bring it
to other country this was totally
inspiring hopefully all of you will go
out and do something creative today
thank you so much guys
you